well
it is a bit of an emotional time for me
it has been a long 22 years
but it's been a very encouraging
inspiring time
thank you for making the positive
comments
and for those of you seven have never
experienced my
techniques for you quite a
it's quiet hard to comment on
the past 22 years there's all sorts of
various stories you could always
bring up but i would like first off to
thank all the
past students that have come today and
past
teachers that this is canon and mr hello
exceptionally
good friends and
it's just a few little pointers mr
of mentions a few things about the past
but
some of the things that go on now are
indirectly due to me unfortunately came
here in 1992 which was mentioned
in 1999 uh i got the first
four units due to crosstalk for quite a
number of years
but then they decided
things are going well in 2000
we'll have three classes at full unit
and then the parents break up some more
and then the following year we have
four places and that's why you have four
classes today
on the assumption that i was going to be
here forever
but time catches up with everyone
the interesting thing about 1999
there's always numbers that you'll never
forget
and there were a lot of students that
you
get a hundred in their own subject and
poor unit
the i had one student get
92 but
out of the 29 students the average
was 99.3
and i don't think any year since then
has come close
i think that number is virtually
important
and over the years since i've been here
i've nearly had since
97 uh the fourth and class only of the
second year
and there was a dry spell in the early
2000s
but the number of students
that have actually got a 100 ui
for 100 tr or 99.95
a car at present totals
35
and i think that number in itself is
rather astonishing
there's a couple of other little things
you often remember
as time goes on for the
year 9 year 10 year 11 and year 12
you do trigonometry and you remember the
mnemonic
astc
in all the textbooks it's written as
all stations to central
when i started teaching here i changed
it a little bit
and i said all students to concentrate
and then one of my students
decided that wasn't good enough it's
all students to come below
now i've received a lot of very
interesting gifts and presents over the
years
uh but i've almost mentioned that
year eight last year that was something
that
would miss me for the rest of my life
first up it was
a coloured map of how to go between here
and cumberland
then it was a mug
but make sure i didn't forget the
direction the direction was shown on the
mat
uh but one of the interesting things i
got from year 12 after the
year for one year after the card and
the guest a student gave me
a special card and it was about two or
three paragraphs of
kind words but
during the year we had talked about
breaking codes interesting things you're
doing masks when you're
that necessarily has to do everything in
the course
pose based on statistical nature and a
few other things
well i took the letter to one side
and she had spent hours and hours
and i broke the cave and the cold simply
said
mr alder is an awesome mass teacher
i thought that was very very memorable
uh
i think that the school has a lot of
promise
a lot of good things for the future
i do appreciate everyone that's here at
the moment
and the speech is given by various
knowledge very memorable
it's been an interesting career
and we just have to take stock of time
and future aspirations and health
and put everything into perspective
i wish you all the best for the
coming years and wish to school all the
best
thank you